how you doing you edgy radicals i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message it's october 14th of the year
2021 share subscribe tap the
notification bell yada yada okie dokie
we're doing a q a today we've got a
gajillion question submitted over at
rubinreport.locals.com but before i get
to that i just want to say i'm feeling
good about stuff
i think something might be shifting i
sense a disturbance in the force and a
good kind of disturbance you know
yesterday i covered how cnn actually had
two doctors on saying that uh vaccines
that you know the vaccine mandate so
that you can get on a plane would not be
necessary would not be a good idea i
talked to you about how our sheriff here
in los angeles is saying he's not going
to force
officers to be vaccinated i sense a
little pushback there was the southwest
airlines employees who
basically caused a whole bunch of flight
delays because they're against mandates
people seem to be pushing back and
that's actually a perfect lead in for
this first story that we're going to
cover today and then i'll jump into the
q a
cnn's lead doctor sanjay gupta you see
sanjay on tv all the time he's always
telling people what they should and
shouldn't put in their bodies and he's a
very respected guy he's the chief
medical correspondent over there on cnn
well he went on joe rogan and as you
know rogan does these three hour long
form interviews basically no script just
talking it out and watch what happened
to dr sanjay gupta when he's not reading
off a teleprompter it's about a
two-minute clip and then we will analyze
joe rogan yes i would say you've had it
yes so now get one shot of the vaccine
no why not because i have better
immunity than i would if i was
vaccinated we so right yeah
i think your immunity is really good so
why if i've already gotten through covid
and i was really only sick for a day and
then five days later i was negative
and i do have the natural antibodies now
why would i take a chance in getting
vaccinated on top of that by the way i'm
glad you're you're you're better i think
that it only lasted a day you're
probably the only one at cnn that's glad
no no no no no no no the rest of them
are all lying about me taking horse
medication
we should talk about that that bothered
you it should bother you too they're
lying at your network about people
taking human drugs versus drugs
calling it a horse to worm is not a
flattering thing i get it it's a lie
it's a lie on a news network and it's a
lie that's a willing
that's that's a lie that they're
conscious of this is not a mistake yeah
they're unfavorably framing it as
veterinary medicine
well the fda put this thing out you saw
that did you see that thing that the fda
put out what did the fda put out
it was a tweet and it was snarky i admit
it they said you are not a horse you are
not a cow stop taking the stuff or
something like that why would you say
that when you're talking about a drug
that's been given out to billions and
billions of people a drug that was
responsible for one of the inventors of
it making nobel prize nobel prize in
2015 15. yeah yeah a drug that has been
shown to stop viral replication in vitro
you know that right why would they lie
and say that's horsty warmer i can
afford people medicine [ __ ]
this is ridiculous it's just a lot like
anyone but don't you think that a lie
like that is dangerous on a news network
when you know that they know they're
lying you know that they know that i
took medicine like here it is
this is ivermectin you gotta sit right
here somebody gave it to me
all right hang on i i do the thing is
we're we're like going so fast like i
feel like i'm missing a mystery you
think that's a problem that your news
network is not lies
well i don't i don't think dude what did
they say they lied what did they say i
was taking horse dewormer first of all
it was prescribed to me by a doctor yeah
yeah they shouldn't have said it was a
bunch of other medications if you got a
human
pill because there were people that were
taking it the veterinary medication and
i you're not obviously you got it from a
doctor so that it shouldn't be called
that ivermectin can be a very effective
medication
for parasitic disease and as you say
it's probably you know i think what a
quarter billion people have taken it
around the world i get that way more so
way more billions of people have taken
it can i just come back to the one i
want to talk about
two things on the ledger you have before
we get to that does it bother you that
the news network you worked for out and
out lied well outright lied about me
taking horse dewormer they they
shouldn't have said that why did they do
that i don't know you didn't ask i
didn't think that you're the magical guy
over there i didn't ask i should have
asked what they did was such glee
okay that is an absolute
beautiful clip and i'd just like to give
a slow clap to joe rogan right there
because he's not even making this about
the specifics about the covid treatments
and all of that and the efficacy of all
of these different things he's really
just saying cnn you guys lie and sanjay
you're the doctor on the network that
lies and do you have a problem with that
and sanjay really doesn't answer him one
way or another if i'm not mistaken and i
will correct myself if i'm wrong i think
i saw a clip this morning from a few
months ago on cnn where sanjay himself
calls it a horse dewormer so we're going
to try to find the clip but i'm pretty
sure i actually saw that this morning
he also sanjay did something pretty
extraordinary right at the top when
rogan said you know i've had covet i
have immunity i took these medications
blah blah blah he says yes you have
better immunity you have better immunity
why are we not talking about that on cnn
i mean that's the point that i think joe
is trying to get across why are we not
talking about natural immunity as i've
been talking about why are we not
talking about flattening the curve why
are we not talking about herd immunity
any of those things so rogan just really
really i think did a bang-up job there
and it also shows you you know i always
talk about that chasm between sort of
the mainstream media and then the online
media right and how that chasm keeps
getting bigger and bigger and i think
this is a perfect example of why these
guys don't really do these shows anymore
i'm not sitting here saying sanjay gupt
is a horrible person
i think he's probably somewhat
compromised by having to work at cnn and
they they care about narrative over
truth but i think he's probably a decent
guy who doesn't want people to get sick
but when he's confronted with someone
who isn't in the shackles of little
sound bites and who isn't purely driven
by ideology which obviously joe isn't
well then sanjay kind of folds there's
many other moments in the interview that
that are worth watching but if you don't
think any of that is interesting it
started making me think i i've heard
sanjay gupta talk about an experimental
drug too i'm pretty sure i had heard it
somewhere and then it reminded me of
this clip when sanjay was talking about
rib of aaron why doesn't he talk about
rib of aaron anymore because he was into
it here i know it's tough to hear i've
already gotten a lot of a lot of emails
and social about the fact that i call
this humanitarian disaster but i i stand
by it it is and hopefully it inspires
people to do something about it there
are stories circulating on the internet
that in india and elsewhere the drug rib
of aaron has been shown to be effective
against this virus
yet homeland security is telling the cdc
not to make any announcements until
stockpiles of the drug could be secured
dr gupta there continue to be
evaluations of several drugs ribavarian
is among them
but right now our best defense has been
social distancing no hand shaking
staying home when you're sick washing
your hands frequently
you see what i did there people that was
dr sanjay gupta playing dr sanjay gupta
in the movie about a pandemic contagion
it's a fantastic movie if you haven't
seen it and of course there's lawrence
fishburn no that's not morpheus from the
matrix that's lawrence fishburn who is
an actor pretending to be the head of
the cdc but sanjay for some reason they
can't get actors to play the doctors and
the cnn people they always have them
play themselves everyone else uh you
know is allowed to get an actor to play
them
so yes just to be clear before i get
deleted for having
shared misinformation ribavarian is not
a real drug and sanjay gupta in the
movie contagion is not
a real doctor
however morpheus in the matrix that's
real for sure i have no doubt about that
anyway i just thought this was super
interesting and just to reiterate what i
said at the top i think there are some
cracks that are starting to show whether
it's southwest employees pushing back
whether it's doctors saying you're not
going to get sick on a plane whether
it's parents saying hey i want more
information before we inject our kids
all of this is sort of leading to
something but notice which way it's
coming from it's coming from us the
people it's not coming because the
government is like oh maybe we've gone
too far down this road maybe we're
pushing people too far maybe we do think
doing things that are unconstitutional
it's coming from us the people and guess
what you person watching this you're you
the people and you have a chance to fix
this yourself
on that note let's do a little q a we
got a bunch of questions submitted at
reubenreport.locals.com so let's take as
many as we can missy
says do you think that deep down
leftists are still convinced that the
country is better off now this is a
great question that gets to
intentions versus outcome right so i
talked to rand paul a couple days ago
and and i asked him some version of that
also which is you know at what point do
these people who bring in all of the bad
policies at what point do we say that
their motives are no longer good and
what he said which is uh you know sort
of common phrase it's like they have a
big heart and a small brain meaning they
want to help poor people they want to
help black people and gay people of the
downtrodden but their brain is small so
everything that they do hurts those
people and then hurts the rest of us by
extension so i don't know that there are
many leftists wandering around right now
or even forget like hardcore leftist
progressive marxists if you're just sort
of the average
i would say slightly confused or don't
care about politics that much democrat
could you possibly think this thing's
going well right now as you're looking
at the price of gas and now these videos
are coming out where we're having
shortages at you know supermarkets
and when you see after what happens in
afghanistan and you see the federal
government you know trying to force
states to do things and like the series
of things that we all know we all know
something ain't right right now we know
something ain't right with biden like
all of the stuff if you're just the
average person that pays a little bit of
attention to it well you might pay a
little more attention when you go to the
supermarket and they either don't have
something or you notice that the price
of chicken is up 25
or whatever it might be so i don't think
that the average person thinks things
are going well i think the activist base
and the ridiculous media they're loving
it because there is a desire i'm sorry i
i have to impugn their motives in this
case
there is an absolute desire to destroy
this country believe people when they
tell you what they want to do and bernie
wanted to burn it all down these are the
ideas that these people have brought in
aoc and ilhan and the rest of them they
don't think america is good nancy and
chuck who i don't think are crazy
anti-american radicals they're just not
in charge of their own party and it's
pushed by the media and it's fueled by
big tech and all of those things
but i don't think that the average
leftist realizes it that's my hope at
least and what i would then hope is that
you know we've got midterm elections
coming up in about a year from now and
my hope would be that there would be the
most ridiculous red
wave of all time and i know that saying
that is sort of crazy if you know my
long history but reality is what it is
and you don't have to be a republican
but you cannot be a democrat if you
think america is decent and we must get
rid of these people and we must fight
back and i don't know what i don't know
what they think in their heart of hearts
but i know that their actions are
destroying the country so at some point
i guess this is the
the highlight reel on this one
at some point it's irrelevant that would
be the point if you keep getting
everything wrong or if the results of
your big heart keep destroying things
and keep making crime go up and and keep
making communities unsafe and all of
those things and keep making people more
depressed and locked at home and all of
the problems people have because of all
the covet stuff well then it doesn't
matter if you have a big heart
congratulations that you have a big
heart which big hearts by the way that's
one of the side effects of one of the
vaccines that right like this is
something that young young males a
certain percentage of them it's a very
small percentage but it is something are
getting in large hearts and we're
probably not allowed to talk about that
it's been nice knowing you
but again i'm not telling you what to do
with related to the vaccine but the
point is at some point your good
intentions as they as they you know the
road that you're paving with those
things as that thing goes off the cliff
and there's a whole bunch of monsters
down there and they're hungry you know
rancor pit we got a problem abby says
what are your thoughts on the luden
county cover-up so this story is
absolutely insane if you haven't heard
about it i actually just did an hour and
a half
on megan kelly's podcast this morning so
you can find that on her youtube channel
i think the full thing's up already if
you didn't see it
or you can listen to it on siriusxm
where we covered this the short of it is
for brevity's sake here um there was a
girl in lewden county virginia a young
girl i think high school was in high
school or junior high can we get the age
on her i think maybe it was high school
but in effect she was raped by a boy who
was dressed at a girl in a school
bathroom i suppose the boy claims he was
trans it doesn't even matter that's not
really what this is about and then there
was just like a series of cover-ups it
was a high school girl okay there was a
series of cover-ups at the school
superintendents moving people to
different districts and basically it's
one of those things where everybody
didn't want to make it seem like they
were a transphobe so then what do you do
you you sacrifice at the altar of
tolerance and diversity you sacrifice a
raped high school girl that's what all
of these people did it's an
extraordinary story it's not getting
much mainstream coverage of course
because they don't want to expose the
insanity of their good intentions we
just want trans kids to feel uh included
and by the way that's perfectly fine
but when it leads to a young girl being
raped by a boy who's dressed as a woman
whether he fully identifies or trans or
whatever it is we got a problem here
daley wire by the way is doing a great
job of covering this you're you're not
going to find much on cnn or new york
times or anything else and again this is
one of those things if you believe in
ideology that we have to protect trans
people above truth which is ah i'd
prefer that young girls not be raped in
bathrooms uh then all sorts of horrible
things happen so maybe we'll cover it
more next week it's just it's just a
horrific horrific story and it's just so
it's so obviously the extension of
everything that we talk about on the
show all the time uh vivian says to
change it up what's your favorite
halloween candy and what is your least
favorite
without question i love the reese's
peanut butter cup okay
i i love the cup i don't mind the big
cup they have a super big cup it can be
a bit much and i like the uh the little
cups right i'm down with that hate the
candy corn it's disgusting nobody should
be eating it it doesn't taste good you
feel horrible after you eat three of
them but a nice peanut butter chocolate
dessert who doesn't love it landon and
as far as i understand there's no wrong
way to eat one so that's very exciting
landon says do you think the biden
administration's attempt to enforce a
national vaccine mandate will backfire
politically and legally this little
connected to the first question well
we're starting to see pushback we're
starting to see people that are going
hey you know i've kind of been okay with
a lot of crazy stuff and i don't really
say what i think when it comes to a lot
of stuff and
but now it's coming to my house right
now i work at home i work remotely i
haven't been to the office in a year and
a half but i have to be
jabbed by something because my company
says so because the biden administration
uh ordered a press release to be sent
out because it wasn't even an executive
action as we covered yesterday it was
for federal workers and contractors but
not for uh for ordinary companies then
people start going oh this stuff's
really hitting home or if right now i
mean just think about it right now
we don't have kids yet we're working on
it and god willing it'll happen but if i
had an eleven-year-old child right now
and here in california where they're
demanding that all children 12 and up be
vaccinated and by the way newsome has
already said he wants it to be five and
up but if you had an 11 year old child
right now and we know that that there is
virtually zero chance of children
getting sick from covid not zero chance
.002 check the covid check the cdc
numbers on cobit but kids aren't
transmitting it to each other et cetera
et cetera the teachers generally are
vaccinated especially in a place like
california if you had some hesitancy as
a parent if you just whatever your
personal hesitancy was whether it was a
religious belief or whether you just
don't like the government forcing people
to do things or you believe that your
child's immunity is kept up you feed the
child well the kid exercises they're out
and about
what would you do if your kid is now
facing three months away they're gonna
be 12 in three months and they're gonna
have to get vaccinated so the more that
they push things that make people
sort of in their day-to-day life in
their home with the children that they
love and the spouse that they love the
more they push holy cow the government
is making us do things that will
literally affect you
right like the person who i share a bed
with the person
who i sit on the couch with and watch tv
shows it's like now they can start
igniting people to push back and i sense
that that's what's happening right now
what their next move will be i mean if
we real if people really start standing
up i mean how can they call us all
racists and all anti-vaxxers and fire
all of us
i don't know i don't know but there's
there's some hope in the system right
now i really feel it right now i hope
you do too
joe says i'm seriously considering
running for congress by primarying the
current gop incumbent here in florida's
12th district talk me out of it i think
the only way we get out of this mess is
if normal everyday people take over the
house and start working in the best
interest of the people and not the
powerful donor class joe why am i
talking you out of it
you just said it that's it
regular people regular people getting
involved whether you're getting involved
politically whether you're getting
involved in your local community whether
you're going to school boards whether
you're not that i want to put you on an
fbi list whatever you're doing in your
life to fight back that is it so talk me
out of it i get i get what you're doing
there
right because people wanted me to run
for governor of california and i still
get all sorts of people asking me to do
all sorts of things and it's like man it
will be a headache joe like no doubt
about it will they try to pull up stuff
on you yes
will will they do unimaginably horrible
things because i suspect you're a decent
you know human being right like will
they do horrible things to you yeah well
your opponents do worse things than you
want to do yeah but good people are
getting involved if you didn't watch my
interview with blake masters who's
running for uh republican uh running
republican
on the republican side for uh senator in
arizona it's like check out that injury
this is a decent guy i've spent some
time with him he's a nice decent man who
did not want to be a politician and he's
feeling that he has to get involved to
push back jd vance is another one in
ohio you know it's like these are not
people who wanted to be politicians
these are people who actually just
wanted to be decent people
but it's getting hard to be a decent
person right now because politics has
become so crazy because the left has has
decided they are here to destroy the
whole damn thing and until enough of us
say no they're going to keep moving on
us right and and one big way you can say
no i'm not going to participate in the
lie i'm not going to keep letting you
take away my freedoms i'm not going to
let you keep marching on all the whole
thing all the things that i hold dear
well one way you can do it is by getting
involved politically so i get it man i
get why you'd want to be talked out of
it but i'm not going to do that with the
way you phrased that question you seem
like exactly the type of person that
should get involved and how about this
joe
if you get involved i will have you on
the show there's my commitment let's
contact joe directly if joe will run for
political office i will put him on the
show there you go
tallway says not a political question
but i've always been curious what your
favorite holiday is
and what day means the most to you i'll
answer that in two ways i would say my
favorite holiday is thanksgiving um you
know the idea that we have this purely
secular holiday to be thankful for all
of the good things for america on top of
the fact that david's an incredible chef
it's the one holiday that we host here
at the house it's with all his side of
the family and uh and they're all great
chefs so like our food is amazing but
it's like this great time to just be
appreciative of all the good things of
america and for someone like me who's in
the political fight all the time and you
know some of the just endless nonsense
that that
it's not i want to make it about me but
that i have to deal with in terms of the
public part of my life and and fighting
for for the goodness of this country
that there's a day that we like stop and
and
and honor that that this thing is so
freaking good and you better remember
that you better remember that because in
10 years if we keep going the direction
we're going you're to go man remember
that america maybe we're starting
starting to get there anyway even though
i'm hopeful on this pushback right now
we are kind of veering in that way right
doesn't it kind of feel like that if
most of us could just go back to say
seven years ago and we'd just be like if
that's the america we could have again
and feel like we could maybe fight a
little more then well if you think you
should have fought a little more then
we should probably
fight a little more right now so i would
say thanksgiving in that regard i would
say in the last two or three years um
you know as i've sort of come around
more on my my the spiritual side of
myself and the religious side on the
traditional side um i would say passover
has become very important you know
passover
obviously which is the story of the jews
exodus from egypt into into the holy
land and into israel even though i know
the modern left thinks jews have nothing
to do with that place even though
there's all this uh hebrew written on
all these artifacts from thousands of
years ago but okay um you know the story
of people sort of reclaiming their
identity and moving forward and and uh
not
not just accepting what a totalitarian
regime wants it feels valuable to me
right like the pharaoh owned these
people they were slaves in a strange
land and there are messages in that that
are valuable right now about standing up
for what is right and and fighting for
what you believe in and all that so i've
found passover uh to be particularly
poignant over the last couple years and
also you've got to drink four cups of
wine so that's pretty good that's pretty
good
storm says our city assembly just voted
to reinstate the mass mandate after some
vulgar people spoke out against it how
do we get the best people to speak out
against this without getting crazy so
first off i don't know what what city
that is but
more mass mandates really
really october 2021 and you're gonna
force people to put cloth on their face
at this point does the vaccine work or
not can people make choices for
themselves or not if you're vaccinated
and wearing a mask why would you force
someone else to do the exact same thing
unless you're an anti-vaxxer i'm really
sorry to hear that i don't know what
city we're talking about i'd like to
know i mean still here in l.a these
idiots are still doing it um i just
don't leave my house and everything's
just fine here you guys are good right
you're good oh and by the way michael
you're feeling 95 today remember michael
was a little bit of the sniffles so he
didn't come in one day he came in
yesterday he was at what were you at
yesterday what percentage would you say
90. he was at 90 yesterday he's at 95.
no one has dropped dead here connor
you're right connor's okay so
everything's fine around here because we
let people make choices for themselves i
didn't demand he have an experimental
procedure
to work for me
um
so your question though is what's the
best thing we can do is start talking
man start talking in your town to your
friends and your neighbors and maybe
with a little bit of humor kind of hint
to people what you believe boy we're out
you know your neighbors mowing the lawn
you're walking the dog uh you know it's
nice to be outside without a mask isn't
it and then they might go boy you know
it is nice to be outside without a mask
that guy doesn't seem completely bananas
next thing you know you're having dinner
with these people turns out you agree on
a whole bunch of other stuff actually
there's a little bit in my next book
about this sort of thing and how we can
sort of rebuild things bottom up and
with neighbors and your local community
and all that
sherry says what's your best guess about
the biden spending package do aoc and
the progressives compromise down to 2
trillion if so will manchin and cinema
agree or does the current pressure make
mansion and cinema blink
so i'll answer the second part first on
the blink part like are they just going
to keep pushing 3.5 trillion and now
i've heard they even want to get it to
four like are they just going to keep
pushing that keep calling kristen cinema
far right maniac keep attacking joe
manchin these are democrats by the way
is the media just going to keep trying
to destroy these people and have people
show up and accost them in bathrooms and
on airports and at airplane uh you know
all these things like is that the route
that we're going to go and will that
break them eventually
i suspect that's not going to break them
actually i think they knew it was kind
of coming it's not fun to be accosted in
a bathroom or on an airplane or at an
airport
but i don't think that's going to break
them if anything i think it's showing
them boy we're really fighting some
radical nuttiness and it's radical
nuttiness that the democrats obviously
have wanted to be here just watch the
video we played last week that we've
played a few times maxine waters get up
in their faces don't let these people
have dinner peacefully et cetera et
cetera this is what the democrats want
they want a hyper-polarized
political society so they can keep
attaining power throughout it because
everything will feel so hysterical only
they
through tolerance and diversity can make
everything okay um so as for your
question whether whether they get this
down to 2 trillion or not look they've
got some negotiating power right i think
there was a
letter sent from manchin to chuck
schumer a few months back where he said
he was never going to sign anything over
2 billion does that sound familiar i
think it was over 2 billion maybe it was
2.5 so look this is what politics are
about it's about negotiation so mansion
had stuck out a position it was either 2
or 2.5 billion he had said that months
ago so then they they basically doubled
that right they went to 3.5 4 billion so
it's like
uh let's see oh he had wanted what was
it i'm sorry trillion i'm sorry i keep
saying billion uh he wanted uh 2
trillion you know they're trying 3.5
maybe 4.
so the point is
this is what politics is it's a it's a
negotiating process i suspect they're
not going to blink but then the question
is will will the rest of the democrats
blink like they're so radical that will
they be like oh two is enough and by the
way it costs whatever the number
whatever the final number is it does
cost that number it doesn't cost zero
just because you're taking it from other
people doesn't mean it costs nothing
kyle says as unlikely as it sounds what
would you think of a ron desantis tulsi
gabbard presidential vp unity ticket in
2024
well first off i think it would be
freaking
fantastic that's number one and i will
even go a step further and i don't know
that rod desantis or or tulsi gabbard
will be thrilled if i say this
i don't think it's that unlikely i
actually think there might be a decent
shot of something like that happening
ron desantis you all know my feelings
about him he has been just sort of the
dictionary definition of what a governor
is supposed to be especially in these
last
two years he has fought to keep his
state open he has let people make
choices he has kept critical race theory
out he's not doing mandates he is trying
to keep the economy alive trying to let
people flourish with some uh personal
choice spectacular and i think he's a
good guy and he's willing to fight he's
got a great uh i think his press
secretary this girl i think her name is
christina
pershaw or pusha she's just fantastic
so they've got a team that's fighting
the right way then you've got tulsi and
now what's interesting about tulsi is as
radical and crazy as sort of all of the
democrats have gone please i ask you
guys all the time it's like show me
a mainstream democrat either in the
press or or a political
operative a senator a congresswoman
somebody that doesn't seem like a total
lunatic or radical right now tulsi is
the one tulsi is the one tulsi believes
that america is decent tulsi actually
you know the reason she hasn't been
around much over the last couple months
is she's she's still serving in the
military right now uh tulsi i think is
is basically a moderate with some lefty
leanings and she's willing to talk about
all these things but she believes in
capitalism she believes that america is
decent she believes we should keep this
country all these things i don't know
that there's a home for her in the
democratic party so there's an
interesting idea there it's like
desantis take the lead tulsi come and
make all of those moderates that huge
group of people
make them here i'm going to go this way
that was to my right i'll go this way
they're on the left we're going to bring
them over and show you that the
republican party is not that radical or
mean or racist or anything i think
they're really really really is
something there i hope neither one of
them are pissed at me for saying it but
i really think it is possible and uh and
wouldn't that be wouldn't that be pretty
freaking healing like who in there i
know the media can can do all sorts of
things and and make uh
make everybody seem like a radical and a
racist and all that stuff but like you'd
have to be bananas you'd have to be
truly like off your rock or crazy to be
like oh this tag team of ron desantis a
pretty moderate republican
but i get it a little trumpy but pretty
moderate republican and tulsi governed a
very freaking
mainstream democrat of 10 years ago
these are the bad guys that's the bad
team these are the crazy right-wingers
coming to destroy the country it would
it would be so ludicrous um that
that i think we could get a lot of
people and i also think both of their
temperaments are right and tulsi who i
know a bit more is just an absolutely
lovely person and i think that that's
the chance man that's the chance i like
it
uh phoenix says any updates coming to
locals soon like new features bundles
and private messaging ah i wish i could
tell you everything right now okay we
have major major major major major
major stuff going on with locals we
should have some announcements uh very
soon there's a lot cooking at the moment
we are working on bundling by the way to
directly answer that one i know a lot of
you you know if you subscribe to me and
you subscribe to scott adams and you
subscribe to greg gutfeld or whoever it
might be that that does start adding up
and we don't want cost to preclude
anyone from joining any of the
communities we built this first to free
creators that was the the original
intention right we built it for me first
like how could i be free of big tech and
then we spun it off to all these other
people
who want to be free as well
so bundling wasn't in the idea bundling
is very complex by the way because if if
we're like okay well it's
a 20 bundle to get 10 creators well now
those 10 creators only get two dollars
each but maybe they were charging five
monthly uh so we have to figure out the
finances you know you can say okay this
person's more
popular has more followers so they're
going to get a little bit more of the
money and then you start figuring out
ways to fiddle awesome it's extremely
complex and you have to get all the
creators to be on board but yes we are
working on that yes we are working on
private messaging i really want that um
you know these things take a little bit
of time to build but we're working on
private messaging as you know we we just
well now it's been about two months but
we do have live video streaming on there
but i want you guys to be able to
communicate with each other privately
right now we've got a news feed and
people can comment and like and all that
stuff but it's in the public setting
although you can set your your own posts
to be private but i want people to be
able to contact one on one not like sort
of on the main front page front facing
page so we're working on a whole bunch
of other stuff and and some big
announcements hopefully uh in the next
week or ten days or so rhiannon says do
you have a favorite musician or band
rhiannon well you know rhiannon by uh
fleetwood mac uh is it rihanna yeah
rhiannon but not rihanna that's that's
that umbrella woman rihanna invited
weirwood mac great song i love fleetwood
mac they're probably my favorite like
band of all time like just like the
breadth of work we got engaged at a
fleetwood mac concert we've seen
fleetwood mac live a million times
absolutely love them stevie nicks is
like just the most transcended just
google stevie nicks dancing the girl is
just she's just incredible
um but you guys know i love the old
crooner so i love sinatra i love dean
martin i absolutely adore
frankie valli
if you want like some other stuff that i
can tell you i listen a lot
during the day here when my guys are
working here i have a lot of pat metheny
on in the background which is it's
instrumental kind of chill relaxed stuff
the ripping tins i really like kind of a
little up more also not not vocals just
uh just sort of tunes to like you know
kind of keep your mind going throughout
the day and uh i'll give you one more
well i think you guys know i i love a
lot of classic rock too that's sort of
within the fleetwood mac situation but i
once got busted for smoke and pot at a
journey concert in orange county i was
outdoors with kelly carlin my friend
kelly carl and george carla's daughter
we were smoking a little weed a couple
years back
obviously i've got the glaucoma and i
couldn't see the stage and she said oh
i've got a little something that might
help and we're smoking a little weed and
we got busted at an outdoor journey
concert i thought you had to smoke weed
at an outdoor journey concert in orange
county we got busted there
elizabeth says curious to know if you're
following all of the protests in europe
and if you think they're making a
difference seems like they've been
protesting for months yeah nothing's
changing there is some crazy stuff going
on in europe right now you know i've
tried to talk a bit on the show about
australia we're going to talk a little
bit more about australia tomorrow during
the panel
i've got sydney watson on
who is australian originally she's doing
a new show with elijah shaffer over at
the blaze now so we're going to talk a
little bit about what's going on in
australia but in terms of europe there
are massive anti-mandate
protests happening in italy they're
happening in france they're happening in
germany now note you're not seeing any
of these on mainstream media are you
you're not seeing any of these when you
tune into abc or cbs or nbc or cnn or
msnbc or any of that why would they not
be showing that when there's thousands
of people
in major cities in europe protesting
vaccine mandates could it be that they
don't want you to see that people are
pushing back
could it be that they don't want you to
see that because they don't want you to
start doing that here
could it be that they're kind of almost
working for the government
could i be a complete conspiracy
theorist some of this is starting to
make some sense
anyway yes i i will do more on each of
these things just this morning i mean
just before we started i saw some crazy
protests in italy people just want to be
free these are and don't let the
narrative fool you people want to be
free these are not crazy anti-vaxxers
who want people to die of
rubella and other things okay these are
people who want to make medical
decisions for themselves and if you push
people far enough you don't let them go
to work and then you know the the stock
on shelves starts depleting because of
all the other mandates that you've got
and they've got you know all these
videos now of our ports where goods
aren't getting out i mentioned the other
day try to buy a couch but do a little
test when i'm done with the show today
go to cb2 creighton barrel go to west
elm where else do people get couches go
to like any of the places that you would
buy a couch just put it literally put in
any couch
and try to buy it and see when the
delivery date is and from what i'm
seeing because we were going to buy a
couch everything now is like march april
to buy a couch remember in the old days
remember when america was america and
you could buy a couch and have it
delivered in three days yeah those days
are long gone my friend but i think
we're going to get them back because i'm
feeling good guys part four of my
interview with michael shellenberger who
wrote a great book san francisco how
progressives destroy cities and indeed
they do
is up right now you can always play
along with us at reubenreport.locals.com
the full interview's there already and
tomorrow as i said we've got sydney
watson from the blaze she's got a new
show out with elijah shaffer who i've
had on before
from the blaze and jesse kelly from the
first will be making his reuben report
debut i should have had the guy on two
years ago it just sort of fell through
the cracks
and by the way sydney and elijah's new
show is called you are here so you can
check that out on blaze tv or on youtube
or wherever you watch stuff you can
figure it out you know i i have faith in
you it's the internet type something see
what happens uh anyway busy day today uh
oh we've got uh lauren bobert in studio
a little bit later today and then we'll
be uh releasing that as that next week
and i believe we'll be releasing that
next week so anyway i gotta do some
stuff so i assume you have something to
do right maybe you're hungry for lunch
maybe you want to take a walk maybe
you've got work to do i don't know how
am i supposed to know anyway see ya